in the movie you play mother-daughter
and obviously you get on but you get on
in a kind of fun mom daughter way or you
more like just regular friends in the
movie nobody in life I live I'm here we
talked about actually I don't think it's
uh I don't feel age difference but yeah
I do feel amazed many times I can feel
like a maternal you know which is normal
yes uh and I think was I look at Amy and
I watch her she could bend my daughter
from your lips good again my daughter
yeah the look would have been a troubled
daughter it would have been someone I
had to deal with definitely she's gonna
made the great baby but you I would have
loved to have come out of you can I say
that that's really good yeah the lovely
things that yeah but I'm all rosy for
that one
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah oh my god you have you have hung
out with Goldie's family haven't you
like you know yeah yeah I have to tell
you the other night about Kurt so we
like I go over to their house the other
night for dinner and and Kurt answered
the door and he was so sweet and he just
gave me the warmest hello he was like it
is so great to finally meet you I you
know I love you Goldie loves you I love
you and so warm and and I was like oh my
gosh Thank You Kurt
we sat next to each other at the Golden
Globes family remembers meeting me where
Norn here if you'd like to see even more
stuff like that then hit subscribe or
don't free world but I know what I do in
that situation